I gotta do this I gotta do this because
it's it's it's it is more government but
it's also how the left has become the
moral authoritarian so let me let me
start the second by asking you guys a
question
which political party
Pop Quiz everybody was trying to get
content and music banned in the 90s
which political faction the Republicans
it was the Republicans I was born in 96
so I don't remember oh yeah well like
like 90s I remember so uh Magic the
Gathering for instance we actually have
this card downstairs called Unholy
strength Magic the Gathering of course
is a strategic card game with fantasy
themes and there's an image of a guy
with a pentagram behind him and it was
conservative religious families who
complained and forced the company to
remove the image of the pentagram
because it was satanic check out this
story Illinois lawmaker seeks ban of
Grand Theft Auto game following rise in
carjackings and which political party
does this Illinois lawmaker who is
trying to ban a video game belong to
what would you guess well the the party
affiliation is not in the title so I
know so the rule so the rule is Democrat
sure
a Democrat is trying to get a video game
banned this is it I'm sorry everybody if
let's first of all when was the last
Grand Theft Auto game made 2013 no no
more recent than that no GTA 5 20
2016. yeah sure yeah uh but I remember
seeing so many Republicans when when one
of the Grand Theft Autos had a scene
with a working woman 2013. is it really
they ported it to PC later yeah yeah but
I remember I remember GTA
uh five came out for PS3 is that really
the latest Grand Theft Auto it's been
it's been it's been a hot minute yeah
it's been a while it's been a hot minute
so listen listen you got a guy a
Democrat trying to ban a video game
that's what going on like eight years
old because carjackings went up I Blame
You Ian I see the list you're the one
who said it doesn't make people want to
carjack cars it just makes it easier to
do that's that's what I think he watches
the video with Ian describing what he
said and he came to that conclusion the
one super chatter said like video game
violence I was like do video games make
people more commit more violence it was
like no doesn't make people want to do
it it just makes it easier to pull the
trigger they do it that's why they train
soldiers exactly yeah we talked to uh we
talked to somebody about that they say
sold the military will use these uh like
from the ranch yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
it doesn't make people more likely to it
makes it easier for those too so that I
understand the Family Guy did a whole
cutaway about that about video games
What specifically Grand Theft Auto where
Pierre loses his memory and she's like
oh just here play this game so you can
remember how to drive and then you see
so this this Illinois guy rep Marcus
Evans Jr has introduced a bill that
would amend a pre-existing law Banning
certain video games from being sold to
minors his Amendment would ban the sale
of games with subject matter including
motor vehicle theft with a driver or
passenger present the amendment has yet
to be voted on there would have been
there have been renewed debates around
the ban of carjack ban after carjackings
among young people have gone up recently
the bill would Revit the sale of some of
these games that promote the activities
that we're suffering from in our
communities a 16 year old was arrested
and charged with carjacking on Monday
days ago there were two 15 year olds
arrested I gotta just say I really don't
think these kids are playing GTA and
then being like dude I got an idea let's
go carjack for real yeah oh that's so
smart and they high-five and they go
outside and they're like yo give me your
car and that's that's that I don't know
we live in a generation of Tide Pods
that's true nobody was eating Tide Pods
but when it comes to intelligence by and
large and it comes to our education
system We are failing that's the bigger
point I'm making here for sure but but
also most importantly especially with
this Grand Theft Auto thing I I believe
it was Republicans that made it so you
needed to show an ID card to show that
you're old enough to buy certain video
games just a few years ago I remember
there was such a massive outcry against
GTA there was one particular scene with
a working woman that everyone was
screaming about and they actually came
pretty close in Banning the video game a
couple years ago so it's just absolutely
absurd to still see this nonsensical
argument being made right now but it's
the perfect representation of what
government is absolutely absurd and
stupid I don't I don't know about that
Republican ID thing I just tried to
Google I couldn't find it but I but I do
have the story where the Verge writes
Trump and Republicans continue to blame
video games for their failures on gun
control they say there's no evidence but
it's a talking point that has been
repeated since Columbine amazing
following two uh we'll call them Mass
tragic events they say lawmakers and
government officials offers thought and
prayers they take no action House
minority leader Kevin told Fox and
Friends that video games dehumanize
individuals in a speech day president
Trump pointed at video games
specifically as the root cause of these
events we must stop the glorification of
violence in our society he said this
includes the gruesome and grisly video
games that are now commonplace
sounds like Ian when you when you said
before that you know video games were
leading to this you were far right I
would like to ask Julio about this
because you're actually in the military
yeah in the reserves what what branch
the military are you in Marine Corps and
what what do you think about violence in
video games and how it Associates I mean
there's I don't think that's true in the
sen in the sense that that's the cause
for it I mean you have to look at just
the the whole environment and obviously
who the person is I mean I I think in
terms of desensitizing maybe yeah but in
terms of it being the trigger behind it
no I don't know or like encouraging it
encouraging it yeah because you you
separate the I mean it is an interesting
point that Trump Republicans are then
bringing up dehumanizing essentially
like we learned from the uh it was it
was the the fellow from fortitude is
that what were you saying yeah he was
saying the military so actually I
brought this up because there's this
movie called The Men Who Stare at Goats
yeah and it was this like project where
they tried doing psychic spies a real
thing apparently and in the movie you've
got uh what's the guy's name is it Jeff
Bridges the actor is that his name I
don't know that's right which one the
actor in the movie The State men of
share goats they're talking about how he
was in Vietnam and this like Vietnamese
woman runs out into a field and all of
the American soldiers they don't shoot
and then he's like what are you doing
start shooting and they shoot up to
purposefully Miss and so the dude who
was here said the way they combat that
is using active targets like actually
they used to do they used to just do
like a Target now they do a shape like a
person and they do first person video
games so that now it's in the people's
minds of what a person looks like so the
the general idea is that video games
don't make people more violent but a
violent person would this would help
them essentially if they were going to
commit an act they would not be averse
to shooting a person right
I mean I I I don't know I mean I I again
I just I I just have a hard time I just
have a hard time believing that that
that's the that's the main factor that's
gonna drive somebody I mean and you look
at the I mean you just look at the the
history I mean you you don't want to
talk about be careful when you talk
about Mental Illness but Adam Lanza from
uh the uh the new town right I mean
there's there's just so many other
things although I think he did I think
he did play video games though I think
well I I think everybody plays video
games yeah well right right they used to
play Dungeons and Dragons was going to
make kids go crazy and it's violence I
mean I will say I mean because like from
from the riots that that I've that I
covered a lot I mean it was just back to
back to back and and I I found myself
being very bored at and and so I think
there was an adrenaline aspect for
certain high stress events uh and not
necessarily school shootings but I I can
see that because there was some stuff
that would happen that that I would see
and report on and it would be sad and be
tragic but I have a hard time
finding emotion behind it just because I
had seen it over and over and over
personally that would be the decision
that'd be kind of the desensitization
aspect and so like I would recognize
that it would like okay like this is bad
and this is sad but
um it didn't have the same effect the
very first they do this to many police
departments they play very violent Riot
footage and officers getting hurt right
before they go out I've seen the many
reports of this uh before they go out
cover many protests or a lot of them are
jacked up a lot of them are you know
ready to to you know prepare to defend
themselves and most protests you know
usually don't don't get violent they're
becoming more and more violent uh but
again psychologically the video is such
an important component in in making
people realize that's that's there's
something else bigger out there it plays
on the imagination but also plays on
your visceral senses where you get to
see it and you get inundated in it in
such a way where you believe you're
actually in it so video is one of the
biggest forms of propaganda that we
should be of course made aware of and
especially question when certain
traumatic videos are being played over
and over and over again it's especially
on mainstream media dude I was watching
you were watching a movie yesterday or
something and it was like a guy just
hitting another guy just beating on his
face oh taken taken taken three yet
another violent movie I mean we're
talking about so much violence in the
movie industry it was punching even all
the Marvel movies just punching and
beating and throwing and Blasting
listening everything like 90 I'm I'm
just giving an exaggerated number but
the overall majority of content is
violence guns every every Marvel movie
every Marvel these are some of the
biggest movies ever made literally all
of them violence the Mandalorian
Mandalorian that's all violence it was
great yeah Game of Thrones violence war
video games violence conflict the
biggest games like even Minecraft has
violence in it to a certain degree yeah
sure it's not the worst I shouldn't rag
on Minecraft but you look at some of the
biggest games fortnite violence I don't
know people are still playing fortnite
uh Grand Theft Auto the game where you
drive around run people over and do
crazy things there is this component of
video games that conflict is one of the
big components of our entertainment I
wonder why that is I'd love to talk to a
psychologist or you know a psychologist
about this what about violence is like
such an entertaining value for us is it
because it's conflict because it's risk
it's a threat it scares you and then you
overcome it what we've seen from this is
there have been feminists who want to
create what what people call walking
Sims walking simulators video games
where it's like your mission is to go
and hold hands with someone and earn
points because they want to get away
from that but people don't like it
people like even if you go back to Mario
like the original Mario on NES you play
a dude who runs around punching bricks
and stomping Turtles and then kicking
them it's like it's fast-paced geometric
competition kind of like throwing
baseballs at each other like dodgeball
but it doesn't have to be shooting
someone and killing them it just is in
the Visage of that so like I think why
people like it is because it's
fast-paced geometry and you're learning
how how like what's that Splatoon what's
Splatoon you were a bunch of like squid
Critter people and you sprayed paint on
them yeah same fast-paced geometry so
that's what that's what we're really
learning is how to interact um hand-eye
coordination we're challenging each
other to see who's got faster reflexes
but it's in the guise of a violent gun
you know it's it's the AR it's all these
realistic guns the graphics are getting
so realistic that if you're in it in
like VR you'll you'll really maybe even
start to believe you're killing someone
like it's possible I got it right now
the big problem is not the Republicans
for the most part this it's a Democrat
who wants to ban these video games the
only thing we have to do to make sure
that nobody comes and bends our video
games is make all of the bad guys have
Donald Trump's face
nailed it there it is because think
about it Republicans might actually
complain and say I demand this game bad
but who's going to listen to the
Republicans they can't get anything done
they'll be like I am upset about the you
know these these games got to get banned
I'll say get out of here shut up and
then if you make all the all all of the
NPCs any character that could die has
Donald Trump's face the left will be
like I see nothing wrong with this
all violent you made the most gruesome
and brutal violent video game like Doom
was legit like super violent but just
you know make a trump and and they'll
they'll allow it they'll stop
complaining they'll immediately come to
the defense someone should make a mod
for GTA where everyone's faces Donald
Trump and show it to that Democrat and
he'll go oh oh oh you know what I think
this game is actually okay I withdrawn
my bill
I I'm a huge Video Game Nerd as you
probably know if you don't know I'm a
huge Video Game Nerd here we go um I got
really mixed feelings about video game
violence like I wasn't allowed to watch
violent movies growing up yeah same here
because they didn't want to twist my
mind my parents I saw a Nightmare on Elm
Street too when I was like 10 and I
remember the veins getting sucked out of
that guy and it like stuck in my brain
for month for years still to this day I
can see it his skin turning white as his
veins were getting it was so gross like
just messed me up and that was one thing
that I saw as a kid I was like I wasn't
allowed to watch Tom and Jerry or The
Three Stooges or married with Children
like I was and did I I'm so I'm aware
like the violence man how it can
brainwash you but I don't want to ban it
I don't know this is this is it is
interesting I think you know we do have
to be careful about what kids are
watching yeah and are doing but that's
not that's not incumbent upon government
it's it's it's it's the parents it's a
family role thing we were just talking
about there's a video of Ron Paul that
went viral and it is one of the most
glorious videos of Ron Paul ever Luke
was like I've seen that video a million
times I just retweeted it I said Ron
Paul is a legend it's it's basically a
bunch of people who are like band drugs
say no and Ron Paul's like government
shouldn't be the one deciding what you
do with your life but there's this
really glorious moment where he's
arguing with a guy and he goes you're
not going to get morality from the
government the government can't make you
a better person why don't they put you
on a diet you're a little overweight and
everyone's like oh look and I was just
like yes Ron Paul he's right if if look
if you're like the government should
tell us what we can or can't do it's
like okay well they should tell you to
put down the fork no that's not the way
it works so when it comes to video games
when it comes to South Park when it
comes to Beavis and Butthead whatever
these shows are because you know booze
and Butthead believe it or not it's
coming back all right and and parents
have complained about it it's your fault
I'm sick and tired of this and this is
this really for for the most part uh
become endemic on the left I mean I know
the right used to be about banning
things they're like oh these things are
bad for kids and you know we got to ban
this art now it's really the left it's
like yo the left are the ones coming out
saying I should have no responsibility
it is a kava too what you said about
Adam Lanza was pretty enlightening like
I think it goes deeper into the the
psychoactive drug system and how it's
making people crazy and then we're
talking about parents taking
responsibility for what their kids are
consuming but like you want to see you
can be inundated with violence but if
you're on psychotropics that's going to
be sure and what I'm trying what I'm
trying to bring up specifically and
focus on is you've got too many people
in this country whether it's people who
have kids or somebody who just eats
terrible food who says you should pay
for my health care even though I lay
around eating double you know Big Macs
with extra sauce and don't exercise or
this video game made someone crazy so we
should have government take it away from
everybody else or a crazy person with a
gun therefore no one should be allowed
to have guns right it's meaningless yeah
I mean and so that's why I'm adverse to
when it comes to like video games
because it's the same one argument when
it comes to gun control and one of the
reasons why I became conservative was
looking at the various gun control
arguments uh made by Republicans and
Democrats and I was thinking well the
Democrats want doesn't make any sense
and you know what else are they being
misleading about and so that's kind of
how I went down the road right it's it's
remarkable how
if you're if you're being logical and
you hear the conservative argument on
guns you're going to hear something
typically they're going to say
this ex like I the first memes I saw was
why is this gun band and this gun not
banned and they're the same gun so one
meme is the Ruger 1022 I saw yep there's
a wooden stock Ruger 1022 and then
there's a like polymer stock with a
pistol grip Ruger 1022 literally the
same gun same capacity same firing and
everything you just hold it a little bit
different ones under risk of being
banned as an assault weapon and one
isn't it's it's meaningless so when I
would actually go to you know the left
the traditional liberal people and say
why is this gun banned and say oh
assault weapons got to be banned and I'm
like they're the same gun it makes no
sense and you can't get a logical answer
out of these people because they don't
know what they're talking about and so
I'm just like listen if you can't be
responsible for your own life why should
I have to pay the price and that is a
serious challenge I am actually fairly
left on a ton of policies I totally
believe in Cooperative economics and
systems of government but there is a
limit we have to be Liberty oriented not
Authority oriented and so what you have
with these traditional liberals is they
actually I love this meme from leftists
they're like Democrats are actually
authoritarian right and I'm like yes
that's correct that is absolutely true
the Democratic establishment are
somewhat they're not super far right all
at the top but they are in the
authoritarian rights spectrum they want
to take away from you they want to
dictate what you do and they are not
overtly far left but they're close to
the left so they're they're like they're
I'm sorry they're they're more
authoritarian right and there's a
difference between libertarian right
where it's like hey man do your thing be
free and free trade authoritarian writer
crony Democrat corporatist Democrats who
have revolving door policies prop up
International corporations and big Tech
firms empowering the corporations and
then also telling you what you can or
can't do with your life so I actually I
actually think the Democrats and
Republicans the demopolitans are fairly
in the same place you do have
Progressive Democrats who I think too
much indulge in the cult stuff and then
you have a lot of good libertarian
Republican candidate black politicians
people like well Rand Paul obviously Ron
Paul retired now Thomas Massey and a few
others you have very few actual good
principled Democrats at all but I would
say it's a tiny fraction that are
actually on the libertarian Spectrum so
I tell you if if you believe in Freedom
I don't care if you're an echo-communist
far left you know critical race woke
whatever if you're on the libertarian
spectrum and your whole thing is well I
disagree with you but I don't believe in
being violent and hurting others or
forcing people to do things I'll bet we
get along man come over have a beer
let's grab some slide grab a slice pizza
or vegan pizza that's what you're into
and then the laissez-faire capitalists
can come and you know and then sell us
his great pizza and we can all hang out
together as long as we all agree not to
oppress and beat and harm each other
that's not what we're getting we're
getting tons of moral authoritarians who
want to use the power of government
because they think other people
shouldn't do things or they want to
extract the value and labor from other
people because they're not responsible
for themselves thanks for checking out
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time